foreign
[Music]
you find a wallet filled with money do
you keep it or do you bring it to your
local police station this situation
might be easy to solve but researchers
often face more complex ethical dilemmas
in addition to knowing what research is
it's also important to ask what good
research is
is it only empirical reproducible and
valid or should it also be ethical
ethics are moral principles that guide
how we determine right and wrong whereas
laws are codified rules people must
follow to maintain social order ethics
are the Norms of conduct people should
follow to promote ideal human character
and behavior by following ethical
guidelines we act in a way that is good
instead of bad we use ethical principles
every day without realizing it when
returning a lost wallet or ticking
responsibility for a mistake instead of
blaming someone else
and Academia plagiarism cheating and
Fabrication of information are examples
of unethical Behavior
ethical standards are not universally
agreed upon leading to different answers
to the same problem the entire research
process relies on ethics from what we
decide to study and how research is
conducted to how participants are
treated and how contributions are cited
ethics are even important when examining
the sources of funding even though
ethical standards can vary by region
discipline or institution there are
common themes that determine what makes
research ethical being honest
transparent and respecting
confidentiality and intellectual
property are some examples different
organizations often have their own codes
of ethics for example the world economic
Forum young scientists Community lists
seven key principles for achieving
ethical research
who decides what is ethical and what is
unethical
in Academia and Industry ethics
committees are responsible for reviewing
research proposals monitoring their
implementation and following up on their
results committees have the authority to
approve reject halt or modify studies if
they determine the research to be
unethical these committees consist of
people from different backgrounds
scientists and non-scientists alike to
offer different perspectives on ethics
there are different types of committees
depending on whom or what is involved in
the study
committees make ethical decisions based
on certain principles for research with
human subjects the institutional review
board uses the Belmont report as the
foundation for its decisions the Belmont
report created in 1974 lists three key
principles respect for persons
beneficence and Justice by putting the
principles of the Belmont report into
action the institutional review board
considers informed consent to make sure
participants understand what they are
asked to do for the study evaluates the
potential risks compared to the
potential benefits and judges that the
selection of participants is fair with
special protections for vulnerable
populations while there are ethical
guidelines in place unethical research
can still happen in any discipline
the piltdown man one of the most famous
frauds in archeology was accepted as the
missing evolutionary link between apes
and early humans for decades however the
remains were actually from two known
species filed and stained to look like a
new one
this dishonesty discredited accurate
findings of early human remains in Asia
and Africa delaying the process of
understanding human history
another example the Tuskegee experiment
was designed to study the effects of
syphilis in black men without their
informed consent even after penicillin
became a known cure for the disease
researchers did not provide adequate
treatment to their participants who
eventually died or experienced severe
long-term health problems as a result of
syphilis finally the monster study was
conducted at the University of Iowa to
find a cause or cure for stuttering 22
orphan children who were unaware that
they were participants in this study
were given either positive speech
therapy which included praise
reassurance and encouragement or
negative speech therapy which included
belittlement and immediate criticism
some of the children who received
negative speech therapy retained speech
problems throughout their lives
there are different reasons why
unethical research occurs it may be
motivated by a desire for recognition
and fame to get a project done quickly
to publish a finding first or to climb
up the academic ladder
prejudices and biases may also lead to
ethical violations public mistrust of
science harm to individuals loss of
funding and even the loss of jobs are
some of the consequences of unethical
research while some of the effects of
unethical research can't be undone
actions have been taken to prevent
unethical research from happening in the
future for instance the crimes against
humanity during World War II brought
about the Nuremberg code the first
International document to advocate for
informed consent and voluntary
participation in research involving
human subjects because of the Tuskegee
experiment the United States passed the
national research act to regulate
biomedical and behavioral research the
Committee created by the Act was also
responsible for writing the Belmont
report
today ethical questions continue to
shape the way we think about research
consider Gene editing a modern
Innovation to explore some of these
questions by altering our DNA do we risk
creating a modern day Eugenics Movement
by breeding out undesired traits is
genetic data private enough to protect
personal information will Gene editing
worsen social inequalities this is not
an exhaustive summary of The Many roles
ethics play in research and the many
topics researchers must consider
ethical training such as courses and
workshops prepares current and future
researchers to work in their desired
discipline with the knowledge of Ethics
researchers can make new discoveries
Guided by the moral compass we all
strive to live by
[Music]
foreign
[Music]